est-ce que vous avez pratiqué le double
jeu vous un politique qu'est ce que vous
appelez le double jeu des promesses
électorales la langue de bois les
magouilles les affaires lors pas du tout
c'est dans quel mouvement vous je suis
au rpr au rfc à moussa c'est connu c'est
koné de jeu démarre démarre faire vos
preuves
bon on va se tutoyer ce sera plus
conviviale ok donc tu penses que toi il
ya trop de double jeu dans la politique
ou ayant un double jeu est ce que pour
faire des [ __ ] est il faut coucher pour
réussir je connais pas ça avait il faut
les rochers avec toute la population
je crois que il faut un nouveau langage
il faut une nouvelle vue de la france il
faut un patriotisme de son pays et de la
défense des intérêts alors on coupe tout
et je me bats pour était mignonne le
double jeu en politique pour quoi pour
vous c'est quoi le double jeu monsieur
il faut pas le jouer
vous les jouez vous monsieur aux jurés
on va parler plus vrai plus direct on va
se tutoyer c'est plus convivial ok
qu'est ce que tu penses du double jeu
toi c'est à dire les magouilles tout ça
tu as tout chez toi il a touché mes yeux
dans les yeux
non non de quoi donc jamais fait quoi
jamais des doigts des enveloppes sous la
table on voit que le dessus il ya pas d
enveloppe qui passent en dessous mais
vous n'avez que ça à dire aux hommes
politiques
le double chez en politique pour vous
c'est quoi je ne sais pas je ne pratique
pas edward une pratique apple il est
vrai que les français n'aiment pas
toujours entendre un salon de vérité est
que ils ont souvent au bout du compte
les parlementaires qui le méritent voyez
là tout le monde a décroché à votre
phrase était longue c'est peut-être un
petit peu ça aussi la langue de bois no
non parce que on ne résume pas une
situation par des formules très court
par des gros titres à sensation non je
crois que les gens mais d'un autre côté
on n'a pas compris une preuve de ce que
vous avez dit c'est vous qui lui avoue
qu'il dise moi je ne sous estime pas
l'intelligence des français et la
capacité qu'ils ont de comprendre des
phrases donc si vous n'êtes pas capable
de comprendre des phrases donc moi je
n'y peux rien si lyon le trac accessible
toi raconte et crack
qu'est ce que c'est que je veux cabu
l'air des villes vous alimentez je crois
effectivement tout 7,7 sort des détritus
à la fois ironique critique à l'égard de
fonctions y compris votre votre activité
dans les classes écoutez c'est vrai que
je décroche je m'excuse je décroche
aussi je décrivais le journalisme
rock'n'roll non on va leur faire on va
se tutoyer c'est plus convivial c'est
comment votre prénom robert ok je vais
t'appeler baby baby baby le double je
t'en penses quoi
j'en pense peu de choses
baby les doublages et à pasqua le
nommera 10 passes de jeu et je pense que
c'est pas du tout ce qui fait gagner en
politique écoutez rock'n'roll
j'essaie pas de conneries le moins
possible merci baby
les régimes qui pratiquent la langue de
bois c'est dégueulasse le coin là non
c'est des pellicules
on sait pas trop chier dans la creuse
sait pas trop ce que je fais pas chier
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça parce
que je venais ouais je vous invite ont
fait du bon boulot tu as envie de quoi
vous organisez des clubs puisque king et
ambiance depuis plus dedeux qu'est ce
que c'est que des activités ou pas varié
avec l'activité web concrètement tous
acquis industriels touristiques
culturelles tout ce que vous voulez il
ya des 27 cents à crouy aussi donné je
voulais frais voire un petit temps
ciao demain je viens pas bouffer un
manche rappeur et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de leonard youtube abonnez
vous y mettez un pouce bleus